[Musique]
au niveau de l'EPA Paris Saclay on
accompagne les entreprises
essentiellement au travers de trois
actions
ces trois actions sont menées en
partenariat étroit avec la french tech
Paris Saclay ça commence par la création
d'un portail qui s'appelle Paris sec les
start-up qui a été initié en 2018 ce
portail permet pour les jeunes
entreprises et porteurs de projets
d'accéder en fait un certain nombre de
ressources et notamment toutes les
structures qui peuvent accompagner les
startups dans leur développement c'est à
dire les incubateurs les accélérateurs
les fablabs ça permet aussi de
répertorier toutes les structures qui
peuvent les accueillir ou les héberger
au sein du territoire de Paris Saclay
donc les espaces de coworking les
pépinières d'entreprises et d'autres
structures et bientôt l'offre
d'immobilités le deuxième volet pour les
startups une fois qu'elles sont
constituées c'est tout simplement de les
référencer dans cette plateforme qui est
un annuaire qui rassemble aujourd'hui
plus de 700 startups ça leur permet
d'avoir une visibilité auprès de
différents publics notamment
investisseurs et industriels puisque
ceci dispose également d'un compte la
plateforme pour aller un petit peu
sourcer et trouver les sociétés qui les
intéressent le deuxième axe c'est lié
aux recherches de financement puisqu'en
fait on organise une à deux fois par an
des learning expédition investisseurs le
concept en fait c'est d'aller chercher
une trentaine d'investisseurs notamment
fonds d'investissement à Paris de les
amener sur le territoire notamment dans
un lieu emblématique de la recherche ou
de l'innovation que ce soit privé et
public et à cette occasion on leur
présente on leur fait pitcher 10
startups dans une thématique dans un
secteur ce qui permet donc du coup de
faire des prises de contact et puis
d'accélérer des levés de fonds pour les
startupers puisque ils peuvent alors
avoir des contacts avec ces
investisseurs et puis le Graal si je
puis dire ou la troisième action majeure
c'est autour de l'événement phare de
l'écosystème qui est Parisse avec les
Springs et notamment autour du label
sprint 50 ou au spring fifty que nous
avons créé en 2021
nous au travers de notre label spring 50
on récompense pas la croissance de ces
startups mais plutôt le potentiel c'est
à dire c'est sont les pépites de l'année
les entreprises qui ont plus de
potentiels et qui nous sommes
intéressants à présenter parce que c'est
pour elle une année charnière de pouvoir
être mise en lumière au travers de cet
événement de pouvoir pitcher devant un
public d'investisseur d'industriels de
partenaires divers et variés sur les
éditions 2021 et 2022 donc les deux
promotions de sprint 50 on est à plus de
150 millions d'euros levés par ces
startups qui étaient présentes à ces
événements donc on espère que la
sélection les lauréats 2023 auront le
même succès que les deux précédentes
[Musique]